[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today the mathematics of general
relativity
part 5 curvature
our mathematical model is almost
complete
using the metric tensor which allows us
to measure distances in space time
we know how to predict the movement of
objects by introducing coordinates
velocity and the geodesic equation
but the great power of our model is that
it makes no assumptions
about the geometry of space-time
in the previous videos our sheet of
paper was always represented as a flat
plane
but nothing prevents us from imagining a
curved paper
on which we can just as easily define
coordinates
and thus describe the movement of
objects
space-time is not always flat its
geometry can be bent
and its curvature will have interesting
effects on the trajectories of bodies if
space-time is curved like a sphere for
example
two parallel geodesics starting from the
equator
will get closer to each other
it is this kind of phenomenon that we
use to model gravity
[Music]
the curvature of a surface is a key
concept in general relativity
and will need a rigorous definition in
order to use it
imagine a plane with a square grid
and a sphere with coordinates of
latitude and longitude
let's place an identical vector on these
two surfaces
on both surfaces we will transport the
vector
up and then right this gives a new image
of the vector
which has been transported along the
surface
now let's transport the same vector to
the same point
but moving it first to the right and
then upwards
on the plane these two images we get are
the same
whether we transport the vector right or
up first
does not influence the final image of
the vector
on the other hand on the sphere the two
images are distinct
they are oriented differently
this effect is what we call curvature
some surfaces are flat the image of the
vector does not depend on how we
transport it
and inversely some surfaces are curved
the path that the vector follows
influences its final orientation
[Music]
[Music]
now that we have a definition for the
concept of curvature
we can express it mathematically
on our surface let's choose a basis
vector
then we choose two coordinates to
transport the vector
we can choose the same coordinate twice
or more interestingly two different
coordinates
we denote them mu and nu
now transport the vector first along mu
then mu and secondly along nu
then mu we thus obtain two
images of the initial vector
performing the difference between these
two images
we get a new vector capital r
if the surface is flat without curvature
r is zero
and the more the surface is curved the
longer
this difference vector becomes
the vector r is the difference between
two derivatives of the basis vector
in opposite orders
indeed we transported the basis vector
first along the coordinate mu
then nu and then along the coordinates
nu
then mu
we saw previously that derivatives of
basis vectors
give us christopher symbols
after a few replacements we get a final
expression for this vector
r that we can break down into its
components
[Music]
the set of all these components these 16
numbers
describe each possibility for
transporting basis vectors along the
surface
is called the riemann curvature tensor
it fully describes the curvature of a
surface
as soon as we know the metric tensor we
can calculate the christopher symbols
and hence determine each component of
this curvature tensor
the riemann tensor encodes the curvature
of a surface
in all possible directions
it is a complete tool for describing
geometry
unfortunately its 16 components make it
a very heavy object to handle
some of these components repeat
themselves
and others are always zero
even worse in the case of a true
four-dimensional space-time
the curvature tensor has 256 components
[Music]
to simplify we need to derive two
efficient tools
that describe curvature but are more
convenient for calculations
the first of these two objects is called
the richie tensor
the rich tensor is represented as a
table
with one row and one column for each
coordinate
to determine a component of the richie
tensor for example its
zero one component we start from our
curvature tensor
among all its components we select those
whose second and fourth indices
are the indices that we want to
calculate
in this case zero and one
among the remaining components we keep
those whose first and third indices are
the same
finally we sum the remaining components
intuitively the richie tenser measures
how volumes change on the surface
when we move along its curvature
on a sphere for example the volume
between two parallel geodesics
decreases as we progress on the surface
[Music]
the components of the richie tensor
measure these variations of volumes
along the different directions of the
surface
but for certain symmetric surfaces like
a sphere
the curvature is the same in all
directions
and we can therefore describe it by a
single number
this number characterizes the average
curvature in all directions
and we call it the richie scalar
in the case where our coordinate system
is orthogonal with axes perpendicular to
each other
the richie scalar is easy to calculate
it is the sum
of each component on the diagonal of the
richie tensor
divided by the same component from the
metric tensor
[Music]
finally let's illustrate this concept of
curvature
with two concrete examples the first
example
is that of an empty space time with
coordinates
t for time on our clock and x
for space along an axis we saw that this
space time is described by the minkowski
metric
which takes the following form
[Music]
the components of the metric tensor in
this empty space time
do not depend on the coordinates they
are the same everywhere on the grid
consequently their derivatives are zero
which implies that the christopher
symbols are all equal to zero therefore
the riemann and richie tenses and the
richie scalar
all vanish
the minkowski space-time is flat it has
no curvature
and two objects starting parallel to
each other will never meet
[Music]
the second example is that of a sphere
at a point on the sphere described by
its latitude and longitude
the metric tensor takes the following
form
this time the metric tensor is not the
same everywhere on the sphere
it depends in particular on the latitude
coordinate
by calculating its derivatives we can
obtain the expressions of the
christopher symbols
and from the christopher symbols we can
calculate the various components
of the riemann tensor the richie tensor
and finally
the richie scalar
on the surface of a sphere the curvature
is positive
which means that two parallel geodesics
tend to approach each other
furthermore the curvature gets smaller
as the radius of the sphere increases
the larger the sphere the flatter its
[Music]
surface
[Music]
you